what is the average penis size
uh the answer is on this board and we're
talking flaccid flaccid it's definitely
the smallest one Turkish if we're
talking me pink one Turkish delight
Turkish delight Dy milk yeah dairy milk
a bit of fudge she's moving mad I going
to say the fudge fudge yeah I say it is
the fudge and it's 3.61 in woohoo are
you surprised by that I've outed myself
there a bit bit Yeah cuz I fud is pinty
wing
no shame in that right and the final
question is does size matter uh
no no the way she looked at him
then I think it should be caramel you
know what I mean does size matter from a
girl yes definitely does yeah if the
girl says it matters then it doesn't
matter well if it's too small it doesn't
touch anything so don't never felt
depends how you use it Size Doesn't
Matter yeah exactly size don't M I think
it need to be in the middle so you can
feel it and it feels good but it's not
too big so you're like o o